what's the contribution you have left he
gave way more than he took you got your
perspective let me give you some like
real real advice that you know you can
Trump because you're in charge
one man's point of view diners sword do
not pander to the short-term situation
in the room
leave them understanding that it's very
cute that they decided to go off of
potential reach because that's what it
is nobody gives a [ __ ] about a lot of
the ads that are being serviced on the
websites that they're moving those
dollars I genuinely believe that what
the internet is doing right now gives
the disproportion advantage to the
people that start off at the bottom
because the cost of entry used to be
blocked by the people at the top but now
the Internet is the game yeah it's the
Gateway sir yeah yeah like your world
like I'm TV had say like like hot 97 had
say like Casey Kasem Dick Clark it Soul
Train TV like SoundCloud has say now
like I want to be humongous I go to
SoundCloud and go put a song up
seriously that's how early I got my
following it's a free platform in yeah
why not
SoundCloud Spotify Facebook YouTube
Instagram get more all the leverage the
only people that will have leverage are
the person that makes it and the
audience and the way used to be was
everybody in the middle to pieces like
guys MTV did not play Michael Jackson
let's just say one more time like just
for you like I want to say it's so
everybody hears it MTV did not play
Michael Jackson on until CBS the radio
like a production like this the record
deal not the state said yo [ __ ] you like
somebody had say in 1984 so that
statement is what I want from you I want
you in my perfect world you would do a
podcast every day this is like let me if
I was a getting complete control and you
were my puppet you would do a podcast
every day that was filmed and then post
produced four pieces of content for all
your [ __ ] Pinterest Twitter Instagram
LinkedIn all of it
yes have you absorbed your content
watched you I can see okay you're
smarter than you look
honestly I don't I'm trying to think
right now cuz I don't want to [ __ ] I
think you might be the first person to
say that recently ever maybe even and I
think it's very interesting because it's
crossed my mind
multiple times you a long time ago there
were these ideas and these thoughts
these collaborations were further super
successful super rich the Rockefeller as
though all these people and what you've
done is you've said alright no more you
can look at your saw so these just
started you can look at the way you do
things and you're making it available to
everybody
and if that's not Robin Hood I don't
know what is and to your point I'm in
Sasha as a company I'm building but like
my great legacy in my aspiration to be
someone that gets written about like
Robin Hood is giving it for free like
the thing that I if somebody asked me
what are you most proud of
I'm literally giving away all my best
[ __ ] for free I don't know what else to
say a lot of people that kind of look
like me build audience to the masses but
then try to sell to that audience right
here's the four thousand dollar ebook
here's the come to my mastermind what I
do is back to your analogy that's why I
thought of it too
I do business with Chase
and Budweiser and Triple A List
celebrities but for the masses it's free
like I really know what I'm talking
about and when I meet anybody and
anything by the way this right we're
about we've had to move this podcast a
couple times I've got this weird day
now I come and sit down say hey I got 20
minutes not 30 right but like for these
next 18 minutes like I'm giving
everything I've got like I'm not
thinking about I don't even know what my
next meeting is I don't there's a
million fires I have going on I don't
give a [ __ ] I need to deliver to this
and I think that's what I do well for
any audience whether it's celebrity the
masses client like I'm obsessed with
over-delivering it's why I say yes to
[ __ ] like this in the first place the
fact that I get one of the emails I get
a day and I get a lot of them that says
I was at I was suicidal like real [ __ ]
that's heavy that trumps anything I will
ever do professionally one one person
telling you that they were going to take
their life and that your [ __ ] videos
in podcast made them not is
disproportionately greater than if I
bought all 32 NFL teams and I mean that
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty six bottles of ye
year or give away thirty six bottles of
wine a year please sign up for Club
empathy this project means the world to
me that could really use your support
[Music]